female
comedians first of all they tend not
always but they tend to structure their
comedy around being masculine and
man-like no dude that's that's what you
do in your 20s okay so it's a lot of uh
a lot of jokes that are based that
basically boil down to hey look how
vulgar I am listen how frankly I talk
about sex I could have been a mother too
okay three times
this is what men usually do but I'm
doing it isn't that funny so it's a lot
of that kind of thing and then also I
think self-deprecation is an essential
ingredient in being funny really funny
comedians are extremely self-deprecating
they're willing to make themselves the
butt of the joke but in particular these
feminist comedians they really struggle
in that regard